last year I volunteered in Ethiopia and
one of the things I saw their female
genital mutilation has completely
changed the path of my life I realized I
couldn't look away from this urgent
issue so I came back to London and
volunteered with an organization and a
friend sent me a link to the YouTube
debates saying someone with an urgent
human rights cause had to go to Davos
and i thought this has got to be it so
why send me to Davos because i want to
ask those innovative and intrepid world
leaders to put their hearts and minds
and power behind ending FGM i just found
out that
since i 1 i've been doing a video diary
every day and really just trying to
raise awareness about the basics of this
very complex issue so what is FGM it's
very simply the removal of a girl's
external genitals the clitoris the labia
and in severe cases the wound that's
left is sewn up so there's only a tiny
home left I'm just pleased the date here
actually because there's been a lot of
prep to get to this point it's night one
in Davos and as you can see it's
absolutely beautiful my belief is that
if she's like this can't stay on the
margins that they really have to be
debated at the highest levels
I'll follow up last year I'm really
delighted I entered this competition who
would have thought ten days later I
would go from my kitchen table to Davos
but let's not be complacent this is just
a few days at Davos there's so much more
to be done there are still three million
girls a year being cut so what can we do
together today to help do something
about this
you